you
oh isn't it funny how whenever somebody
wins a world championship there's always
a standing ovation champagne roses
flowers yet I got a whole backstage area
filled with mutes nobody can believe
that Chris Jericho's the first a e-w
champion pure silence there's no thank
you for Chris Jericho this is a round of
applause
for Chris Jericho but that's okay cuz I
got my own thank you cuz I'm the first a
e-w champion oh you see that bucks Chris
Jericho the first champ how apropos
isn't it yeah thanks that's all you
gonna say yeah no thank you from the
young bucks you know what you know what
even if you did thank me I wouldn't even
accept it okay congratulations on having
Chris Jericho as the new aew champion
the pleasure's all yours Bucky boys huh
you can be quiet all you be quiet
look at you nice hair idiot what's your
name I don't care shut your mouth all
the cops can't believe it paramedics huh
where were you when I was bleeding to
death standing around like a bunch of
morons look at you giant idiot it's your
name first
ayyyy w champion and the whole city of
Chicago the loudest city in the world
renowned for being the best wrestling
crowd in the world
everyone's silent no one knows what to
say cuz Chris Jericho is the first aew
champion Lou this the whole other round
all you guys can stand in the back of
the line oh yeah look at you
librarian you can tell me to shush up
yours
Scorpio sky you'll never get a shot at
this you hear me none of you guys idiots
all right I guess I'll just have to have
my own celebration won't I since nobody
else seems to be here that's fine I'm an
only child
I got no problem celebrating by my sub
with this look at this look that cheap
salami that's what Chris Jericho gets
bunch of crap with olives look at this
look this olives are nothing in there
and you look at this one there's a
little guy in there
can't even get proper all of Scania what
else we got
Oh a little bit of the bubbly want some
bubbly look at this stuff ah he is
bruised he is bloody he is somewhat
insane he is Chris Jericho but he is our
first all elite wrestling to world
heavyweight champion this is alex
Martinez Excalibur what a night here at
all out this is our postgame show and I
tell you what Chris Jericho putting his
money where his mouth is and winning his
head I said I would be the first man to
thank Chris Jericho if he were able to
become the ATW world champion I did it
on air and I'm gonna do it again
Thank You Chris Jericho you have made a
believer out of me Alex this has been an
incredible night of firsts the
first-ever aew event here in the great
city of Chicago Illinois we have the
first tube atw Women's World
Championship competitors here tonight
nyla rose and Rijo indeed and then we
also have the first-ever aew world
champion crowd Indian we're gonna be
hearing comments from hangman Paige
shortly obviously a devastating defeat
for a hangman he is going to be coming
up on stage taking questions from the
median incredible performance but again
no one has been able to stop the Judas
effect Chris Jericho reinventing himself
an incredible move hangman Paige making
his way up to the stage where now we're
going to hear comments from obviously a
very disappointed hangman Paige here on
our all-out postgame show
what are your plans now I don't know I
don't know I I hadn't really I don't
know I hadn't thought of what what it
would be if I didn't win you know I
guess your heart to see you loosen
hanging yeah but unfortunately for
yourself me and you well we have some
unfinished business so let me tell
everyone the real reason I returned to a
a.w straight could you stuff to try to
get them out
[Music]
do you really want to change all eyes
are on me not time to drive it's a
hunger to watch
[Applause]
[Music]
what wrestling was
[Applause]
and realize what it could be
all elite wrestling a new league rises
October 2nd on TNT